but i feel that that's a shame because
now you can never truly be open
within your relationship because you
never truly trust your wife because at
the end of the day she's a woman and
women do x y z so i don't know what you
guys think about that
um
i think that's where again islam has to
be the main program here
because islam teaches us that the dunya
is temporary
right that we we shouldn't be
submitting to anything or anyone in this
dunya only to the creator and that we
should be giving most of our time to the
creator we should have taqwa what is
talk was remembrance of allah right if
you don't have dark well what do you
have you have remembrance of something
else
and a lot of times people get into these
relationships
and
it's
it's not love it's it's an obsession
that they have because they can only
think about this other person now allah
said very clearly in the quran that he
made us so we have passion between each
other
listen
passion and love are very closely linked
you know like you start making passion
with someone feelings develop over time
so if that's not love then what is you
know so people might say oh well this is
love listen no one knows what love is
actually
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
that's crazy because y'all know i like
impactful it was yeah isn't it if you're
watching this it was so it was such a
strong dream
that i woke up
and then i was talking to my dad and i
was crying
because of how strong the dream was how
impactful the dream was
and then i ended up driving to uh the
mosque it was like 5 40 something
to do fajr at the mosque and i was
crying the entire way to the mosque
and suburban lola i think it's crazy
okay so so what i'm seeing is
there's a clash right
there's a clash in world views when it
comes to the pro-red pill muslim
brothers and the anti-red pill muslim
brothers
and the world view that's shared by the
red pill brothers is that
muslim women
a lot of muslim women are like modern
women
they are no different
they may have
certain elements that set them apart
from modern western women but in general
they are women like other women so that
already means that they behave in a
certain way
and they are infected by and affected by
the society that has created modern
women so ideals of feminism and
independence and strong
that is something that muslim women are
are part of they are not immune
to those influences right so pro-red
pill brothers
feel that many of the ideas in red pill
make sense even when you're looking at
muslim women right because muslim women
are like other women whereas what i'm
seeing from the anti-red pill brothers
is that
their idea of muslim women
is that muslim women are not like modern
women that they are better than modern
women that they're even better than the
female nature that is spoken about in
red pill muslim women are above that
muslim women have humility they they
they fear allah they they follow the
quran and the sunnah they're obedient um
you know they're not infected by any of
those ideas happening out in society so
when i hear the anti-red pearl muslim
brothers talking they're always speaking
in terms of ideals
and they're always talking in terms of
the deen says this the dean says that
which is great to understand what islam
says
but if the reality on the ground is that
people are not following islam
then we have a disconnect there's a
mismatch right because you're trying to
bring a purely islamic solution to
people that are not behaving in an
islamic way so
you know it's it's it's really
interesting to kind of see these two
world views clashing because the one is
saying no the dean says this the prophet
saws did that and the wives of the
prophet tell them did this up here and
the red pill guy is like saying yeah but
we're not them and and these sisters are
not them okay this is what's actually
happening on the ground so
subhanallah um i don't think the
argument is going away anytime soon um i
think people's own experiences of you
know interactions with women their own
marriages whether they've succeeded or
failed etc they impact how they come
into this space um but i think a lot of
young men
young muslim men
are definitely
reclaiming their right to masculinity
and i think that is definitely as a
result of red pill and the manosphere
even though
muslims don't need to be taught how to
be men
our men are the most masculine men
alhamdulillah but again
islam is not the only thing that makes
us you know we take ideas from outside
all the time we're being impacted by our
society so i think that the manosphere
has given a lot of young muslim men
permission to own their masculinity and
to start to actually feel proud that i
am a muslim man and i'm not going to
apologize for that nor am i going to
apologize for
the station that allah gave me or even
the rights that allah gave me i'm not
going to apologize for that because
y'all don't like it so that's that's my
analysis that's what i'm seeing yeah
hold up pause for a second
repeat what you said about the whole
masculinity thing
you said something that like oh uh
i think you said muslim men like the
masculine and
repeat it i just i i just want to make
sure that i got it correct what you said
okay inshallah
all right so bismillah
i think we can agree that when it comes
to
traditional masculine and feminine roles
the dean is very clear
right
not only is it clear
in the way that our roles are demarcated
but it's clear because of the role
models that we have
now
the amazing thing about masculinity in
the dean
is that it's not this one-dimensional
caricature of the stoic man who you know
like is never shaken and is never he's
not emotional he's hard he's tough
that's not the example and we know this
because of how allah describes us how he
encouraged us to have humility to submit
to him to submit to authority uh to hold
ourselves to account all of these things
that make us have good character right
men are told to do that too so in islam
masculinity is a lot more holistic and i
would say it is a lot more
there's a wider range that you have
access to as a masculine man in islam
right much wider than in most
traditional cultures because in
traditionally a man is hard he's the
stiff upper lip he's a stoic he don't
cry for nobody he don't take no nothing
from no one you know that whole thing
which is not the example of the prophet
said and then we know that and we've
seen from the sahaba you had the really
tough ones and you had the soft ones you
had the wealthy ones and you had the
fukura you had the ones who were fierce
in battle you had the ones who are poets
so as a man as a muslim man
you've got so many different ways of
being a man on dean you know it's not
just one size fits all
whereas out there there is a kind of a
stereotype of what a manly man is right
so what i'm saying is that in dean the
dean gives us the blueprint for
masculinity and for femininity and how
much space there is within that for you
to be yourself and i think that the
manusphere
has given a lot of younger muslim men
confidence to be proud of being men
again and to reclaim their masculinity
and
their role as men
within the deen you know and the rights
that allah has given them where they're
like i'm not going to apologize for
being a man i'm not going to feel
ashamed of being a man and i'm not going
to feel ashamed of what allah has given
me as a result of the fact that i'm a
man so for me the interesting journey
will be
when our young men now start to
understand the holistic nature of being
a man yes you have rights yes you have a
station yes allah has given you that
that degree over women right
but
there's a responsibility as well
so what does it mean to be a man to be
responsible to be committed to be to be
hard working right to be a leader that
will be a really interesting
conversation when we're starting to see
young men saying
i i'm going to level up so that i can
embody this manhood that i've been given
and be the best version of that for
myself
the women are going to love it
they don't know it yet but trust me when
i say
the sisters who
are out there saying the brothers ain't
this the brothers ain't that a lot of
them
a lot of them have seen examples of men
not being men in the sense of not taking
responsibility
not standing up and taking care of
things because that is in essence what
i don't speak for for all women yeah
because that's just a it's it's you're
on a pathway that you you can't you
can't do anything
in essence
what does a man bring to the table
he provides yes
but more importantly he protects
and it is that strength and it is that
courage and it is that commitment and
steadiness right
that women crave from their man right
whether it's being assertive or whether
it's staying silent you know when she's
going off and not getting drawn into
arguments not kind of going off on an
emotional rant
we value that rock
that should be the man right and i think
a lot of women a lot of sisters maybe
grew up
not seeing that modelled
maybe their father wasn't that maybe
their uncles weren't that maybe their
brothers were spoiled and you know kind
of everybody pandered to them you know
maybe their father didn't have any
self-control whatever so they don't know
what a strong man looks like
and don't know how to be
themselves around a strong man but uh
inshallah the more young men
level up
their deen
their personal their physical their
financial their intellectual
mashallah that that's going to be the
sort after guy that's going to be the
one that sister's like you know even if
he wants me to cook and clean i'm a cook
and clean for him because i know that he
will have my back you know he's he's
going to be
the rock that my family needs and i want
to build with
somebody like that inshallah
there's a lot to unpack uh i've been
saying this since the very first episode
that i believe that red pill is level
two
and islam is level three and people take
that out of context sometimes but
there's no there's no denying from a
personal standpoint anecdotal experience
from my life that i've tremendously
benefited from red pill i grew up in a
world full of lies in this gynocentric
society and the first thing i see that
is even half truth is red pill
so i go into it because i didn't really
have the deen now the reason i can say i
left the red pill today
is because i've gone through it and i
learned and acquired what i got and now
i you know come into being a proper
muslim man
and i'm like red pill aware in a way
it's i i don't know if i could say the
same if i did it the other way around
could i be a good muslim man of course
but would i be aware of the things that
i learned no
and it really did make a difference in
my life
there's a lot of things that we could
talk about such as the whole theory of a
beta male provider
in the manosphere which i don't agree
with whatsoever to be islamic uh the
thing with
and the youth men and all this but uh
that's my two cents on what do you have
to say
i gotta say nothing
i think it's true though i think it's
true
that uh islam is level three
and repta is level two
what's most that i'll say right now i
like that that's actually really that's
that's really that's really profound
actually um i hadn't never hadn't ever
thought of it like that um and it's
almost like
you know if
if i think for well i said um i was
about to say
that if you grew up in an islamic
context red pill might not be necessary
and i think if you grew up away from
modern influences
you could argue that
like red pills it's
it's superfluous right because
like we already have the roles we
already have the characteristics society
is
is helping us to maintain those roles
like red pill is like oh what are you
guys talking about all that stuff yeah
we knew that from time
but i think that the world we live in
today
is much much more integrated than that
and i think almost everywhere you go
modern society has impacted
our our understandings of masculine and
feminine what they even are how they
should be interacting you know the place
of that in a relationship
you know power dynamics roles in a
relationship all of that has definitely
been heavily influenced by modern
society so even if it's a muslim country
you will definitely find some of the
same issues
as what you know red pill kind of you
know
red pill highlighted in modern western
society because that culture is global
and it's kind of to be found everywhere
unless you go to the countryside
somewhere and you see village people
then maybe they are not aware and you
know don't see it as necessary at all
i think that the red pill and islam both
have one thing right which is just
straying away from this
pseudo-apotheosis of women that they're
just virtuous and perfect and there's
nothing wrong with them and
in a way through empiricism through
anecdotal i guess
it's it's essentially evolutionary
psychology
in a nutshell and it's people that
connect to an audience a younger
audience and it teaches them it conveys
these teachings and findings and it
shows men it repels them to the the
reality of women
islam in a way tells us that men and
women both are not perfect and
we're fault we're flawed we're fallible
we have our our imperfections
and i think that personally going
through red pill which is level two
really helped me admire and appreciate
and not take islam for granted
um yeah and people yeah i agree
um
so what are you doing
islam is all
that we should need
and keywords should
right yeah
but we live in a time like you said
where everything is very integrated
times have changed we live in the dunya
it's not perfect
it's not perfect by any means
so
islam should be like the main program
here
and
red pill should be like an add-on
because it i don't know where it was
said i know romney has said this
multiple times i know fire has said this
multiple times
but you
when you live on a land you you
appeal to the rules the laws of that
land right so you can you can function
you can live you can survive on that
land but you still
you have islam like you have your
guidelines in islam so right now this
red pill stuff
it's like an add-on
to the integration that has occurred
nowadays
but if we were to remove this
integration like let's say we had people
living in just a place where
it's basically like a muslim country and
when i say muslim i'm talking about a
legit muslim country not like
the stuff that you see nowadays i'm
talking about like a legit muslim
country if you had some ways like islam
was the main thing
then there'd be no need for that
but the fact is you know we live in that
time where
it's integrated like you you sister you
live in the uk right
um
i don't gotta say nothing there's
beautiful parts in the uk with the the
ummah the muslim ummah but then you you
got the secular parts of the uk
and the same with the west the west is
like a step below uk in terms of that
because we don't really have that like
that muslim ummah over here
you know so that's why i say like this
add-on is actually
something very beneficial but then
here's where the problem lies is that a
lot of the muslim brothers especially
younger muslim brothers because they
live in this area because they live in
the areas where we are so integrated now
into the culture
they start taking the red pill to be the
main program islam to be the add-on
and that's that's where the big problem
occurs
yeah yeah i wanna i wanna jump in here
insha'allah
i think i wanna add something to the
discussion that i think has not been
mentioned yet which is that this
practically an ideology
is a kufr ideology and it has its its
benefits 100 yeah i benefited from it as
well it has its benefits
but it's a ideology that's based in
conference based in liberalism and
that's the main issue with it which is
why i i try and just completely stay
away from praising it or linking it to
islam in any way i know it has his
upsides
but the reason i want to stray away from
it is because what is masculinity like
what is the goal when you look at red
pill the goal is always to have women
why is that the goal
the goal is already messed up
if
i would say majority of the red pill
content out there is about
getting women it's about i would
disagree i would disagree with you i
think you used to worry about getting
respectfully but i think it's more
self-improvement
there's there is there's
there's a spectrum there's a spectrum
right that we can agree that there's a
spectrum you can say let's see one end
to the other yeah yeah harry do you want
to finish please yeah when it comes to
when it comes to
certain ideologies like
liberalism that don't have like a
full-on like book like the quran you can
go to and see the guidelines of it is
always going to be a spectrum so it's
basically whatever is in the current
time
um
that you'll see what it's propagating at
that time maybe red pill in 100 years if
it's around is going to be completely
different right things evolve that's why
there's different waves like feminism
for example there's no guiding
boundaries for it like we have with
islam
most of the time
when it comes to red pill
it is and i stand firm on this it is
about
basically getting women and that's why a
lot of the branches of red pill i don't
want to call them branches but like
things like black pill and mgtow it also
has to do a lot with women and it's
unfortunate but when you have an
ideology that's rooted in something like
you know desires like desire of women
then this is just natural this is what's
going to happen now there are beautiful
aspects like i mentioned like reclaiming
your masculinity being a man right but a
lot of the time it's that's presented
and it's it's with its polar opposite of
with women right it's not always
presented just in a general sense like
islam would uh bring it in and there are
aspects of self-improvement which is
beautiful you know at the beginning of
i'd say the beginning of the man's
journey with red pill it's focus on
yourself get your goals work out get fit
get your money up this that the other
and then it starts to work its way into
okay when it comes to women this is how
you get women this is how you speak game
at them and this that the other it
always gets to that now there can be
benefits to that there can be but from a
non-muslim perspective or from islamic
perspective it's coming from non-muslims
and it's the best to avoid it now what i
think the solution is is that the ummah
needs to straighten out every single man
out there needs to study what it means
to be a man from islamic perspective
that is far on you and if no one's doing
it it's far down the entire ummah
and if you if we are not teaching
something about islam that people need
to know we're all sinful which means all
of us need to get up we just go do our
work we need to teach people islamically
from an islamic perspective what does it
mean to be a man
that way we don't like red poe would
become obsolete and
if you think about it it's really rather
sad that we have to talk about it so
much just to get men's testosterone
levels up again we should be able to
talk about that from an islamic
perspective and and have men feel
masculine again
yeah and sister before you go just to
clarify romney's point when he's talking
about the women uh it's more so that red
pill is rooted
with the uh
i don't know how to say this word
but a woman is at the root of red pill
it's like female-centric yeah it's
female-centric in the terms of uh
it always has something to do with a
woman like thank you you're waking up
but you're waking up from what oh maybe
you had a marriage where the woman was
uh cheating on you or something was
happening you're waking up because you
don't get women you want to get women
you're waking up because um you're not
it's it's
it's always rooted with the women you
know what islam is different that's
that's why i feel like romney's coming
and there's there's no morality that's
also a thing there's no moral compass so
it's all in a way from hedonism now
there are benefits from it we're not
going to deny that
but uh essentially what rami is saying
is if you follow the the islamic model
of masculinity prophet saw some saying
that gopher deen first when you're
looking for a spouse then 99 of these
you know thoughts on youtube that people
are complaining about no one would even
go for them i hate to say it but that's
that's the reality and we wouldn't even
need red pill but you know i still want
to hear what sister knight has to say
lots of food for thought there
jazakallahu
definitely we can say that
the manusphere
is a response
right you could say it's a response to
the increasingly gynocentric society or
the
sidelining of men and men's voices right
the the shutting down of men's spaces
okay and their right to be who they are
and speak as they speak and i think the
manosphere came out of that as a
way of reclaiming male spaces
similarly with red pill
red pill from where i'm standing is a
direct
it's a it's a pushback against feminism
right because if you went back to the
1950s for example when you still had the
traditional family and you still had
marriage being protected
if you still had gender roles within the
home and traditional masculinity was
respected and traditional femininity was
passed down there's no red pill right
there's no need for red pill because
society is on game right like everybody
knows how it works and the things are
as they should be
so the changes that took place from the
60s onwards and definitely the the the
push towards
feminist ideas in the mainstream
big part of what's produced red pill
thinking definitely i agree with that um
and yeah i think to a certain extent you
know you you have a point when you say
that you know a lot of red pill
conversations are about women like you
said either healing from women or you
know waking up to the true nature of
women or how to get women depending on
where you are on the spectrum
but to say that
what you know again again it goes back
to this this idealized version of we
just need to get islam and everything
will be okay because if you rami you
become you know grounded in your islamic
masculinity you still are operating
within a context and that context is
a gynocentric western context so
while i agree with you that what we need
to be doing is teaching our sons and
daughters the correct model of female
you know what it is to be a muslim woman
and what it is to be a muslim man
there will still be utility in these
lenses because the situation is still as
it is and it's probably not going to
change for some time unless you know
things are all the pendulum always
swings doesn't it so right now it's
swinging towards you know
red pill and you know more men speaking
and more women
also saying no we want traditional men
we want to go back to traditional roles
so society this society is always doing
that so yani rami if you stay
firm on your thing and anybody else
who's watching who stays firm on
i know who i am as a muslim man i know
the type of woman that i want to build
with because i know what you know what
life i want for myself then insha'allah
you will be okay but all the guys out
here and all the girls out here who
don't have that grounding they're going
to be dealing with all these issues and
what i'm seeing is
you know how the prophet sallam said
that you know we will follow the
disbelievers like you know like into
like a lizard hole and when i see
the tick tocks that sisters are making i
think you guys have reacted to some i
see them popping up here and there
yanny
there has to be a conversation there has
to be a conversation the mainstream
conference the mainstream is not going
to have the conversation because the
mainstream is in love with women
women can do no wrong women are the
perfectly evolved human being men are
only imperfect because they are so
different from women right and women are
black girl magic and you know boss babes
and all of this type of thing right
women are always pedestalized by the
culture
so they're not going to start having
difficult conversations because why
should they
you know they stand to lose if they have
those conversations so it really is only
men who can start saying hold on a
minute wait
you think that you're going to have
your
you know little phase
and do your riding on carousels and have
everything your way and you know and
have all the men falling at your feet
for as long as you want and then one day
a man is going to wife you and you're
going to play the good wife and all that
kind of thing well actually no
it's only meant that we'll be able to
kind of
call time on this whole game and say
we're not playing anymore but to that
point i want to ask you guys about mgtow
because i received some messages from a
young
brother clearly blackpilled okay and you
i think you know how mgtow boys get down
like when they bring their statistics
and the videos and the thing and and he
was saying
how
as a short ethnic
ugly
uneducated broke man
he's basically an endangered species and
because of women's hypergamy and this
eugenics wawa you know there's nothing
for us like it's basically i i'm i'm
done you know and i was trying to advise
him and said like this is really toxic
like what are you doing like what are
you filling your head with but i mean
have you guys come across any any black
pill dudes and like what do you see
going on
yeah the the black pill stuff and the
metal stuff that's that's a cancer
that's weird bro there's this they use
dolls like a lot of them because they're
like oh screw female nature so this
makes no sense to me yo so a quick story
quick story i
before we got into islam
i was getting into the reptile i was
waking up because i was engaged you know
that didn't go
as planned and then i was like no it's
really her bite so then i started coming
out to the red pill as most dudes do
yeah and then like this one dude he
started talking about mgtown i was like
men going their own way like this sounds
interesting you know like i should be
focusing on myself i should be
the one enjoying the fruits of my labor
versus just giving it all the way to a
woman and then like i started you know
watching some of these guys videos and
like the further i got in i was like yo
this is twisted like this there's
something going on here because this
this man was saying no we don't need
women you know we're going on we're
doing our own thing we're living our
life the way we want to live we don't
have to have someone nagging us
constantly we don't have to provide we
have to do all this we don't have to
give our emotional attention none of
this stuff to a woman but then he over
here has a sex doll stuck for the law
and he's watching pornography stuff for
a lot i'm like yo how are you gonna talk
about women like this but then you're
doing this on the side
so is that the manhattan is that kind of
how it goes it's basically men go your
own way don't deal with real women just
deal with fake women i think those words
are your needs i think that's where it
leads honestly and just think about it
think about this brother that was
telling you all this stuff saying that
oh man may allah make it easy for him
but that he's an endangered species
let me let me add something to what
sister naima said earlier i'm beginning
to see your point it's almost like
if we we believe as muslims that islamic
financial system the islamic economic
system is the right way to go and this
kofar i guess reba filled society for
finance it's not the way to go we agree
on that unanimously
however
by and large every single islamic
scholar in finance specializing in
finance knows exactly how the kuffar
financial system works
and they've studied it extensively
and they know the ins and outs they know
whatever they know what stocks are halal
they know what cryptocurrency coins are
hello
and it's almost like they understand
that they don't do it they refrain from
it but they understand and they use it
as a tool to navigate through living in
this western society
and i think that that goes concordia
with what sister naiman was saying that
if we learn red pill it helps us
navigate in
today's society we could still be muslim
without giving up our identity
she was asking about the black girl
though
yeah i had to tie that up to uh what was
that before yeah
may i just say something i i'm not
advocating learning red pill
i'm not advocating that because it's a
it's a rabbit hole right like most
things on the internet it's a rabbit
hole you go in that space oh you're
gonna get lost in the source so any
young muslim guy who's coming up i
wouldn't say to him yeah yeah yeah start
watching so and so so and so so so and
so yeah you need to learn this red pill
stuff
i think it's more
i i'm grateful for the people of
knowledge who are engaging
with red pill ideas and clarifying for
the people
this is in line with the dean
we don't have any problem with that in
fact the dean came with it first yeah
that we own that stuff we cool this
stuff here is toxic it's dangerous it's
haram it's whatever it is and clarifying
for people so that they themselves can
see
this makes sense to me on a rational
level this is something that i have seen
with my own eyes and it does not
contradict the deen i'm cool with that
you know what i mean uh whereas you know
if we just say
no red pill haram
you're leaving guys basically unarmed in
the battlefield because you know what i
mean because what you're doing if you
say no red pill you don't need red pill
all you need is islam
the reality is most of us are blue pill
conditioned we've been conditioned
already by our environment to believe in
the one to believe in the perfect love
story to pedestalize our women um you
know we the whole all the stories or the
things that we saw in hollywood films
that the guy who wins is the one who
keeps chasing keeps chasing keeps
chasing yeah the one who like keeps
doing things to basically earn her love
we've already learned those lessons
that's in us
so
the dean is not really going to tell you
disney is not true okay we know that
disney's nonsense hollywood's nonsense
but it's in us right
so i'm not here to make a case for red
pill but i i do as i've said before i
speak to my sons and i and i'm my
daughters and i tell them certain things
it's red pill thinking but do i say you
need to be red-pilled no i don't but i
tell them certain things that are
realities that we know doesn't go
against the dean and you need to know
this if you want to be successful in
your relationships because if you follow
what society is telling you as a man
you're going to be a simp you're going
to be a loser you're going to have a
wife who doesn't appreciate you and you
don't know how to handle this
relationship that's what i'm saying
this is this is where i go back my bad
bro this is where i go back to where
it's like redpr has to be this add-on
in this integrated society if we weren't
integrated there's no need for it
because
uh i'll elaborate with my own
you know experience and i'll keep it
very simple very short
but the things that i learned coming on
to redfield like the the biggest things
that made the biggest impact i could
have learned in islam
you know what i'm saying if that was
like the main program but for me at the
time i didn't know islam so all i knew
was the red pill and when i came onto
the red pill
i actually think it did more damage than
it did good
and the reason i say that is because
like you said there's a spectrum
in the red pill there there's
you got some dudes who are advocating
like go out here and have sex with as
many women as you can get the highest
body count ever in crete finance then
you got the other ones over here who are
saying no don't even worry like listen
we don't even want to come close to
women but it's all right we're going to
have the sex dolls and we're going to
watch pornography and all that so
there's a spectrum
and for me like i fell into the spectrum
of like okay i'm gonna increase my body
count i'm gonna go out here and try to
be with as many women as possible i'm
gonna change the way that i interact
with women i'm gonna do all this stuff
but it's like
when i started looking back at all the
interactions i had with women after i
came onto the red pill
it's um it was of that
of the
[Music]
just pure lust type nature wow where
it's like before i had um
connection
with women but it's like there were
certain things that i had to
heal from myself in order to have the
relationship be something better but
like the interaction the connection
everything was more real before
the red pill and it's crazy because the
red pill is supposed to wake you up and
you're supposed to come to the real
thing it's i get it you know there is
humor nature but at the same time like
if you come to a woman and you treat her
in a certain way and you hold a certain
frame the result will be a certain thing
the result will be that lust driven type
outcome versus like
we all have the lust but if you can
interact and you can
interact in a way where you don't have
your insecurities controlling you from
behind the scenes making you act in a
certain way maybe trying to
maybe trying to please the woman maybe
trying to uh
i don't know just be needy and have too
much attention these are things exactly
like if the man takes care of this well
then it's almost like it it works itself
out you know what i'm saying and when
you get into islam
and you get into suju then you're
praying and you you're doing zikr and
all this stuff like
allah is healing you from the inside out
allah is allowing you to become aware of
these things and and that's if you're
doing it you know like really in tune
because there are a lot of people that
do it and you know they don't really
experience anything from you
[Music]
i i like the fact that a lot of people
recently have been saying that
yeah go for it
i need to just turn off them
[Laughter]
i understand that
islam is a religion of guiding people to
the truth it is a complete deen
however islam is not going to teach you
um
for example how to
uh
i don't know
do this in this scenario or do that in
the scenario it'll have generalities
that have principles but it doesn't have
every single application that you need
seriously can you hear us
yeah i was saying that islam is a
religion of guidance but it's not going
to have every single application in a
modern day lens that we might require a
lot of the time people at least the
youth nowadays men young men they can
relate to red pill because it gives
modern day specific examples
where they might look at islam and be
like oh this looks like just generic
principles you know what i mean and i
feel like that's why a lot of men fall
into the trap of just taking red pill as
god
yeah i think i think i agree with you
and also but i also think
it would be unfair for me as a woman you
know who's kind of not in this source
to discount angel's experience and for
us to
assume that muslim boys who come into
red pill will not develop certain ideas
about women
that are not helpful right uh and that
like what angel said sort of make you
see them in a particular way right and
and make you behave in a particular way
with them as well and i think
there are a couple of there are i mean
there are lots of issues with with some
red pill ideas
i think for me as a woman
what i find
the most
because i i can stand something and like
clearly say look i don't agree with that
and i don't like this or whatever
but so i understand where red pill is
coming from i think a lot of it makes a
lot of sense but i think one of the most
dangerous or pernicious aspects of it is
this painting of women
as a species
in a way
that makes them fundamentally
untrustworthy
now
i don't marry women yeah
so i could be completely wrong right i
could be proven wrong 100 times over
but
it seems to me
that if a person is going to say
as a general rule
women are not to be trusted
women say one thing they mean something
else women don't know their own minds
women say they want one thing but
actually what really works is this
and a woman will never love you
like you will never have a woman's love
like because she doesn't operate like
that she doesn't operate like us men we
men when we love we go all in we're
committed we're we stay faithful women
are always looking out for their
self-interest women are controlled by
their hypergamous nature
that type of thing for me
is
problematic and i i don't know i like to
think
that there are women who are self-aware
and and honest and who have tamed their
own desires look at the dean right
when we embrace the deen
we don't just operate on the basis of
our desires we don't even necessarily
operate just on the basis of our nature
we operate on a basis of what will allah
be pleased with and what will he not
right what will bring me closer to him
and what will take me away from him so
even if it's in my nature to be
argumentative for example
one likes to think that a believing
woman understands that even though it's
your nature to be argumentative
it's not right to be argumentative
within your marriage right you
understand like things like that that
set this this this kind of
two-dimensional image of a woman in your
head
and now you just see every woman like
that for me
that's the type of thing that i would
not want my sons to to to kind of take
hold of because i think it makes you
jaded
i think it makes you jaded makes you
cynical
some might say it keeps you protected at
least
but i feel that that's a shame because
now you can never truly be open
within your relationship because you
never truly trust your wife because at
the end of the day she's a woman and
women do xyz so i don't know what you
guys think about that um
i think that's where again islam has to
be the main program here
because islam teaches us that the dunya
is temporary
right that we we shouldn't be
submitting to anything or anyone in this
dunya only to the creator and that we
should be giving most of our time to the
creator we should have taqwa what is the
remembrance of allah right if you don't
have dark well what do you have you have
remembrance of something else and a lot
of times people get into these
relationships
and
it's
it's not love it's it's an obsession
that they have because they can only
think about this other person now allah
said very clearly in the quran that he
made us so we have passion between each
other
listen
passion and love are very closely linked
you know like you start making passion
with someone feelings develop over time
so if that's not love then what is
you know so people might say oh well
this is love this is listen no one knows
what love is actually
it's just this state that we feel so
it's like for someone to say
women are untrustworthy women are like
this women act like this okay
perhaps
you know perhaps many of these women do
but at the end of the day like
you're not
god so stop trying to be god stop trying
to control everything you know you do
your best and then you let allah do the
rest
so it's like you
listen okay maybe maybe a woman might
not be 100 trustworthy but this is where
you do your best by vetting her and
seeing if you actually getting a woman
that is on deep like you said a woman
who is very self-aware and can see okay
i am argumentative but in my marriage or
being argumentative is not going to help
see this you a man would vet for this
now even if he vetted and even if he saw
it for what it was and he's like okay
she's very self-aware and then he
chooses to trust her she can still
break that trust because she is
imperfect just like he is imperfect
exactly and vice versa exactly you know
so all it is is like we have to
we're just playing our part in this
dunya we do our best in this dunya but
we have to remember like this is the
this is just this is temporary this is
so temporary
yeah i really i really appreciate that
yeah because it's very it's panel it's
very holistic right it gives a very
holistic approach whereas usually one i
if anything doesn't on islamic to be
honest it's just going to be um
one-dimensional to be honest like like
red pill feminism is very
one-dimensional because it's it's
literally just about not just the dunya
but this current state of the dunya this
aspect
a few things i want to add is actually i
think i agree very much with angel what
he said i might end up kind of
overlapping things he said but
um firstly i want to comment on the
whole like you know sam doesn't tell you
like what fired was saying sam doesn't
tell you specifically how to do things
so it's not the case that sam always
specifically tells you how to do things
sometimes it does right for example if
you're if your wife is basically
misbehaving not listening islam tells
you exactly what it is that's a kid yeah
there's advocates yeah exactly
subhanallah and that's that's a
beautiful thing but i won't tell you for
example you know when you're driving a
car you know ten and two and it won't
say that but islam gives you a scope
islam gives you what
a scope of permissibility what is what
can you do what can't you do am i
allowed to you know cheat on my wife as
a pun as a punishment for her no for
allah and now it's very very punishable
if there's enough witnesses by death
by islamic law may allah protect us so
islam gives you a scope of what you can
and can't do and i think the the the
main problem with
the whole discussion of islam and red
pill and all of that is
you know a lot of the things that's been
said about it is it really depends on
your view of islam and i think islam we
just made a video talking about how
people in musa when they give lectures
about the afterlife they mainly talk
about jannah
that's a very liberal thing only talking
about things that make you feel good
people need to hear about how that's
what allah
we need to be warned about it not just
reminded that oh there's jannah we need
to know about halal as well so i feel
like a lot of the time
unfortunately even the really mainstream
ones they give a very watered down and
blue pill version of islam and they
don't talk about listen capitalism is
kufur
it is bare bones kuffar we the people
think there's two ideologies capitalism
socialism there's three the third one is
islam and islam is perfect if we lived
in a proper islamic it would be
basically a utopia basically with some
uncertainty and and human error but
other than that would basically be a
utopia there wouldn't be extreme income
tax and and all these societal diseases
that we see when you talk about stem
from that perspective it's like wow i
want to learn that i want to be that i
want to incorporate that in my life but
when people don't talk about it like
that they talk about it like pray and
fast and give charity and then sit and
read quran it's very
sad to be honest there's not much
honestly there's not much room for
masculinity in something like that so
there's this false dichotomy that kind
of is presented to us but when you teach
islam from a proper perspective
then you get the full holistic picture
that that angel was talking about
masha'allah and um
lastly i want to say there's for example
when it comes to red pill and teaching
you know your your like your friends
your family yourself your kids
the young men
things within red pill i think there's a
difference between teaching like using
the arguments that rep hill uses from an
islamic perspective
and crediting islam for that because it
is an islamic thing versus giving it
from readful perspective and then
crediting red pill because now when
people have issues as young men what do
they do they look for red pill youtubers
essentially they read redwater and they
go to non-muslims to how to be a man and
that's why at the beginning i said
khalas cut all that nonsensical stuff
out it may be helpful
do it from an islamic perspective
because islam will give you that window
of permissibility for you to even know
what you can and can't take and i think
susana this is something you said before
that we need we need men to be able to
say this and redfield's allowed this
from red bull is not allowed because it
is out there and it is a thing and it is
big
but i think it is actually i know it
starts with islam and if it doesn't
i think that's a that would be an
individual's problem with islam because
if you say there's anything in the world
that islam doesn't account for then you
don't believe in the ayah and the quran
allah says today i've
you know
perfected your religion and completed my
favor upon you it wouldn't be a holistic
religion for the rest of time if there's
even an ounce of anything that islam
doesn't cover does that make sense
yeah that's crazy because you all know
how like impactful it was yeah isn't it
if you're wasn't this it was so
it was such a strong dream
that i woke up
and then i was talking to my dad and i
was crying
because how strong the dream was how
impactful the dream was
and then i ended up driving to uh the
mosque it was like 5 40 something
to do fajr at the mosque and i was
crying the entire way to the mosque
and subhanallah i think it's crazy that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]